hello this is press talker in this video
I'm going to present the solution to the
puzzler about four equal parts so we had
a trapezoid which we needed to divide
into four equal parts and we wanted each
of those parts to be equal shapes so
instead of trying to subdivide the
original shape into four equal parts the
trick is we can think about a different
perspective about using the original
shape and thinking about tiling that
shape into creating the original shape
again so here's how we can do it we've
used the four original shitty four
pieces of the original shape and we have
recreated the original shape so by
scaling this down we could subdivide the
original shape into four equal parts
each of which is an equal shape
I hope you got the solution it's pretty
interesting it's a nice strategy you can
use for many problems please subscribe
to my channel so you can support me on
patreon catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on Twitter at pressure Walker
and you can get my books listed on my
website